[Musique]
la deuxième journée de visite pour la
ministre d outre-mer annick girardin est
l occasion de découvrir une exploitation
exemplaire en terme d'agriculture bio
une reconversion qui a bénéficié de
l'accompagnement des pouvoirs publics
les collectivités l'état et l'europe
accompagne nos investissements
accompagne notre encadrement accompagne
nos outils de développement donc sur les
dispositifs classiques d'accompagnement
soient des exploitations soit des
structures si on est chez les pionniers
qui collectivement ont décidé avec le
soutien des collectivités notamment du
département d'avancé à la recherche de
solutions adaptées aux territoires et
respectant effectivement cette idée de
d'éviter les les polluants et il ya
effectivement des risques qui sont pris
des risques doivent être mesurées il ya
l'accompagnement qui est indispensable
compagnon scientifique accompagnement
technique accompagnement des pouvoirs
publics
l'état ya toute sa place et doit prendre
effectivement doit être responsable et
doit prendre son rôle à coeur est ici en
le fais moi je me bats pour que les
agriculteurs soient davantage encore
encore soutenu en partenariat avec les
collectivités
je crois que c'est tous ensemble qu'on
peut prendre ce risque une visite qui a
été l'occasion également d'une table
ronde entre les pouvoirs publics et les
acteurs de la filière agricole parmi les
propositions la possibilité pour le
bénéficiaire du rsa d'avoir accès à un
complément de revenus
c'est la volonté du cyrille melchior
président du département qui demande à
la liste de lancer une expérimentation
pour que ces derniers puissent
travailler sur des contrats saisonniers
comme par exemple la cueillette de
fruits ou la coupe de cannes
[Musique]